>> Tucker: EVERY NIGHT THIS WEEK
WE'LL BRING YOU A PIECE WAS OUR
SERIES TECH TYRANNY AND THE WAY
TECH COMPANIES ARE DOMINATING
AMERICAN LIFE IN A WAY IT HASN'T
BEEN HAPPENING BEFORE.
>> AMAZON POWER OVER DATA IS SO
GREAT NOW EVEN THE U.S. MILITARY
IS SEEKING THEIR HELP.
AND WITHIN A FEW WEEKS, THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO REQUEST A 10 BILLION
CONTRACT THAT ALLOWS AMAZON TO
BE THE SOLE PROVIDER OF THE
CLOUD COMPUTING.
AND MATT IS A FELLOW WITH
CITIZENS NONOPLY.
AND THEY ARE PASSING PEOPLE BY
AND NO ONE IS STOPPING TO ASK
PEOPLE BY.
AND WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS OF
THIS.
>> THIS IS HOW THEY BUY
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND THAT
IS THE HEART OF EVERYTHING RIGHT
NOW INCLUDING WAR.
AND SO THIS IS A DECISION BY THE
PENTAGON OR POTENTIAL DECISION
TO DO SOMETHING UNUSUAL.
WHICH IS TO NOT HAVE MULTIPLE
SUPPLIERS OF A KEY RESOURCE THAT
THEY RELY ON IN THIS CASE, DATA.
AND THEY ARE HANDING OVER
A BOTTLE NECK MUCH OUR SECURITY
AND THAT IS WHAT IS CONCERNING
TO PEOPLE.
AND THEY HAVE RELATIONSHIPS ALM
OVER THE WORLTD AND ALL SORTS OF
ENTITTIES AND COULD HAVE
A REASON TO MANIPULATE AMERICAN
NATIONAL SECURITY INTEREST AND
EVEN IF THEY DO A GREAT JOB AND
NO OTHER SERVICES, LAST YEAR,
BECAUSE OF A TIPPO AND AN AMAZON
DATA CENTER AND A BUNCH MUCH
WEBSITES WENT DOWN INCLUDING
PINTEREST AND SECURITIES AND
EXCHANGE COMMISSION.
IT IS A DANGEROUS THING TO AWARD
A CONTRACT OVER A VITAL RESOURCE
OVER TO JUST ONE COMPUTER.